[Musique]
ami de l'homme en noir
bienvenue dans la pire heure de canal
sammer 2012 après le premier jeu basé
sur la vie de ses candidats avec josiane
tagro
elle fournit les cartes sur bruno gaccio
sa vie avec elle en est la triste armée
lâche
t'as vu c'est du théâtre et régis
mailhot
jour sur laquelle alors j'aime principe
ces deux équipes de personnalités vont
jouer sur ce qu'elle préfère elle même
l'enjeu est simple l'équipe gagnante
aura le droit de faire plus de promo que
l'autre est prêt oui prêt à tout pour
gagner bruno la dernière fois on avait
bien fait le point sur la drogue et les
son pouvait s'arrêter
c'est parce que sa première épreuve le
bio quiz
[Applaudissements]
alors chacun d'entre vous la faire
l'objet de deux questions sur sa vie ça
sera à l'équipe adverse de répondre
évidemment un point barre bonnes
réponses on commence avec la vie me
bruneau gauss qu'on connaît bien patrice
et régis c'est à vous de répondre vous
êtes prêts on est prêt c'est nue dans
une baignoire c'est que bruno gaccio a
répondu en avril dernier aux questions
d'un site internet planches point com
mais
à propos de quel magazine bruno gaccio
at il déclaré je veux faire la
couverture ça fait dix ans que j'en rêve
même à poil s'ils le font
voici die match têtu ou playboy moi je
dirais
soit ils suivent ma vie quand je me dis
transparentes s'approchent l'enlever
sexuelle magazine au tournant 8 par la
une oui après le poil mais ne recule
jamais devant le dialogue y compris avec
des personnages controversé
comment s'intitule
le livre écrit par bruno gaccio avec
dieudonné
peut-on rire de tout peut-on tout dire
peut-on tout dire sur les juifs peut-on
être drôle et antisémites
moi j'aurais mis poteau drôle et
antisémites
non non non
c'était n'essayez pas de lire quoi que
ce soit sur mon visage au caire fais je
ne me souviens pas du titre
parce que tu fais tu l'as pas être tu
l'a écrit ou pas ah oui
c'était entretien avec le sujet de
l'entretien avec eux et avec dieu
entretien croisé qui était dans les
collections de ménard d'accord
la
liberté est sympathique
moi j'aurais dit père de tous est trop
banal le dernier soit je serai le plus
drôle ça dure huit récents mais tu lui
jettera les bases y aller quand on est
bon les notices et vite non
c'est aux côtés de dire
oui ouais oui c'est peut-on tout dire
parce que c'était pas seulement autour
de ça c'est la liberté au sens large
donc on peut tout dire mais sur scène et
ça ouais pour moi la scène c'est quelque
chose de sanctuariser quand on est sur
scène on est forcément un personnage
donc on a absolument tout les droits
quand on descend de scène on fait de la
politique comment il va à dieudo est
bien coûte aux dernières nouvelles sur
internet il avait l'air d'aller bien
ouais il avait l'air d'aller bien il
était plein pot antisémites n'ont ni
quel était mon rêve où il n'a pas bougé
patrice et régis vous continuez à jouer
mais cette fois avec la vie de claudia
et humoriste aussi comédienne on va
sombrer ses chaussures pour sandrine
star claudia tagbo à jouer dans un
téléfilm intitulé
sex and the city
sexe combos et beurre salé
s'exprimer la con un sexe m'a fait et
banane plantain
animatrice true blood le sexe comme au
barça oui oui
[Applaudissements]
pas mal du tout c'est quoi cette ligne
c'est un film sur l'intégration enfin
deux amis qui qui qui qui cherchent un
oui aussi un singe palais en fait voilà
donc pourquoi c'est que ça mais pascal
c'est ce qu'a cherché vendre certes du
sexe pour ça
oui balayé tout il est tout content
égalé voir le film juste pour
l'intégration alors sur scène dans son
one man show au crazy claudia parle
beaucoup de sa chute de reins un sujet
qui la suit et même là pour sue
dans quel film de cinéma à jouer claudia
tagbo
menus et des petits culs la seule salle
des jolies fesses à la phase des gros
derrière où la polka des popotins
la salsa des jolies fesses
ouais ou la vallée gros derrière ce
serait un peu habillée ça
qu'est ce que t'en dis allez le losc
dans les gros derrière waro ya
une démarche intellectuelle dernière et
voilà trois points pour vous ces
barrages voies points
car la libye
on continue avec la ville de patrice
carmouze donc c'est à vous de répondre
je connais par coeur je laisse jouer ils
ont dépensé je n'aime pas perdre ils ont
vécu ensemble 51 tollé les gérard
récompense chaque année les plus mauvais
programmes et animateur de la télévision
commence quel gerra a reçu patrice
carmouze
le gérard de l'animateur de compagnie le
gérard du mec qu'on sur tf1 mais
intelligent sur icade
le gérard du journaliste fille déguisée
en lapin la télé tout est vrai parce
qu'il le gérard de l'animateur qui fait
quand même plus que son âge
[Musique]
mais attend le même on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non non non non non moment c'est
forcément une saloperie
non mais ça
c'est pas sympa je trouve banon ne sont
pas sympas les gérards
prix j'hésite entre
anglet le dilemme pas perdre ouais
j'aime pas faire plus quoi faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc c'est une femme c'est moi qui
décide
vraiment depuis le début patrice
carmouze va ainsi le gérard de
l'animateur de
contenus montrez pas tu disais les
démontrer sa
compagnie quand même un gros effet
longtemps
oui
le beaucoup de compagnies moi j'ai connu
sur le câble se l'avouer trévisan voit
la
batterie c'est aujourd'hui sur rtl mais
il a officié sur la radio bfm
comment s'appelait l'émission que
patrice carmouze animé sur bfm 3
carmouze 1/4 sport 2 carmouze 2/4 info
un carmouze trois quarts culture ont un
carmouze sinon rien
non
[Musique]
oh
je n'ai que le diable en soit ce soir là
moi je dirais ça attends tu dis toujours
je me dois
de cette vidéo pour
moi je dis ça pas du bois toi moi
j'hésite entre un carmouze trois cartes
cure
et incarne patrotte away devient culture
ta carmouze et bfm dans la même phrase
par ses
pairs c'est pas joli joli une forme de
délation
direct des mois un carmouze sinon et non
c'est un quart vainqueur
comme quoi les préjugés ouais non mais à
l'époque je faisais c'était une radio
généraliste est qu'aujourd'hui t'aurais
dit quoi j'étais parti soeur de carmaux
pourquoi pas s'engueuler non ce n'est
pas marié rien on n'a même pas encore
commencé votre relation va pas quand
même
gif le la
[Rires]
connais pas fixé sur ses sièges non
alors on termine avec david à gilles
colliard windows est toujours à vous de
répondre
attention régis mailhot et fidèle il a
suivi stéphane bern de france inter à
rtl comment s'intitule la chronique
radio de régis mailhot sur rtl la marque
du mailhot
échange de maillots un maillot deux
pièces où il reste de la mayo
on dirait que c'est pas le dernier la la
moi je le sais un sosie avec lui déjà
donc pour sa voisine on
est c'est l'été
voilà c'est quoi
bravo
dans le domaine de l'humour on
connaissait déjà jacques mailhot pilier
des grosses têtes évidemment et du
théâtre des deux ânes
quel est le lien entre régis mailhot et
jacques mailhot
c'est le fils de c'est le petit-fils de
ses neveux 2 ou celle rien du
passé mais avant j'ai passé le mec
sarine n'y a pas
ce qu'ils
ont fait pas tous ces excellents je suis
raciste
mais comme je connais l'âge de registre
parce qu'il faut croire qu'il n'ya pas
souvent à des
régimes ben oui on se connaît
car si on ne peut pas encore dire parce
que dire en effet que ces histoires
soient les photos ne sont pas vendus
c'est ça
les acheter
ah ouais moi j'ai bon voilà écoute moi
bien oui si on donne pas
voila voila
[Musique]
c'est le neveu de oui bravo
[Applaudissements]
deux bombes tu as ruiné ma vie familiale
que tu m'a embrassée et talbot
tout va bien pas tant de galles à
l'issue du bio quiz 3 barthou
finalement c'est très très bien et nous
attaquons la deuxième épreuve le duo
prise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors je vous lancez une infirmation et
vous devez me dire lequel des membres de
l'autre équipe cela concerne ou bien
aucun des deux chaque bonne réponse pour
un point on commence avec vous parmi vos
adversaires qu'ils trouvent vladimir
putin plutôt rigolo
je peux me dégêner été gêné les
génétique carmouze il est gêné non non
non je crois
c'est là depuis les pages et il est mal
assis 1
pourquoi faudrait-il la question
j'écoule moi je dirais patrice carmouze
mais aucun n'est
[Applaudissements]
que l'acteur
gp sur le câble et près du corps avec
22,9
parmi eux l'adversaire qui a dit je ne
me suis jamais dit embrasant le matin
que je voulais être une vedette
[Musique]
non sauf un registre internet comme ça
tu ne lui voulait tomber
patrice carmouze
regarde
jo-2002 lettres langues et vous en
faites
non mais je trouve ça très beau parent
et de mai qui se lèvent le matin john
est donc c'est un peu comme devenir
président de la république quoi sa
musique un peu par
une adversaire qui a écrit harcelé
sexuellement par stéphane bern
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est uma qui commence à leur écoute des
ratios parmi les avirons qui est
surnommé l'anaconda à cause de la taille
de son sexe
a vécu avec
l'alerté en parallèle est très possible
des pauses
et
commencèrent à aucun des deux camps des
deux candidats
un
footballeur qui sur notre série sur les
ans ils attendent à bras l'enfant
vient discussions de mecs ça oui qui
c'est qui a rappelé
parmi vos adversaires qui est fan de
céline
maillot ouais
[Musique]
non le banjo ses visions
jamais
parmi les adversaires qui a bossé sur
sacré soir
est-ce qu'on est obligé de tout
des cadavres dans les placards des
cas moi j'ai dit oui mais bon c'était
particulier c'est pour ça qu'avec moi
aujourd'hui je me sens en veux mais
[Rires]
[Musique]
tu sais qui je sais pas aucun des deux
aucun des deux bravo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parmi les adversaires qui a cassé les
dents d'un homme sur un plateau télé je
sais qu'à léger s'est battu avec un
autre comédien
mais des dons ont-elles été cassée je
sais pas alors élu n'est pas une époque
carmouze travailler avec quelqu'un qui
faisait tout un tas d'expériences en
tant que seul péter détend
accidentellement
ces bagarres et on m'a dit ça ouais mais
forcément aussi le bon citoyen
mais pas plus car
comment
c'était quand je présentais en effet des
objets et une fois je ne répète jamais
une fois il y avait un type qui avait
inventé un vélo démontable qui avait
voulu à tout prix que me montrer comment
ça marche et et je tiens dans les
coulisses et le buzz alors tout aussi
enlevé sauf le guidon j'arrive pas
l'enlever donc le type s'est rapproché
et s'est rapproché malencontreusement
quand l'une il aurait partie les guidant
le parti dans les deux ans à leucate et
deux dents il avait le méchouar ans en
est on prêt l'émission après non non il
n'était pas dans l'émission miss est l
inventeur qui vous démontre bien le vélo
parmi les adversaires qui était pianiste
chanteur dont débat à
comme ça
en regardant les mains j'ai bon je suis
pas triste honnêtement
on n'a pas tenu tout vu et tout son sens
au début j'étais de montée en gamme avec
il en a monté les gars
à l'épaule
subie
[Musique]
mais qui l'a pas intervenu cadres et
etam
9,3
n'avait pas encore joué
les très bonnes ça c'est vrai attention
c'est à vous de jouer en tant
qu'adversaire
vacances dans des campings nature et on
a tous vécu
qui passe ses vacances de noël
[Musique]
il est interdit d'interdire la tuerie
jamais vu d'abord dans un camp naturiste
mais
vous avez un cerf qui a été embrassée et
on boit cee à pleine bouche par un blanc
à ça je sais c'est qui j'ai vu l'image
elle et elle elle elle était magnifique
je crois qu'il ya un an de loin il y
avait longtemps que si des postes et
galop
comme ça toi et claudia
mais tu verras fait les amygdales le
pauvre garçon
après les faits le camp français dans
l'eau mais en fait moi rien mais lui
depuis voilà pour après les miss et
c'est ça qui a réveillé ses
mains il est plus le même débat mais
jésus je comprends pas pourquoi mais
alain delon non mais pourquoi oui bel
arbre assez un apollon ça j'ai compris
pourquoi on récupère et skate aurait pas
voilà vous de vous n'étiez pas ensemble
ou métier
il fallait récupérer
parmi les adversaires qui utilisent un
gant de toilette comme baigne
ivoirien bellery
parce qu'on parle de moulage veut dire
regarde moi je baigne avec un gant de
toilette
c'est bon non c'est pas mon père est en
grève générale avec ces pratiques
[Musique]
et il fait comme si
c'est un truc de déviance à revendre et
gemma mengual accompagner dans l'autre
voie si c'est forcément quelqu'un je
dirais gaccio c'est un pull de déviants
lagacherie avec dr ouais gaccio c'est
claudia tagbo
je vous aime très fort ça parce qu'en
fait ça comme ça pour avoir cet effet là
j'ai fais pas souvent et c'est comme ça
qu'on peut voir que tu me sauve toi bien
je met du beurre de karité que vous
trouverez à château rouge donc château
rouge de
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'embrasser à la dôle on
parie que vous avez un cercle qui a
toujours une petite cuillère dans son
sac en cas de petite faim
[Musique]
soif et attaques spéciales règlement
c'est un truc de meuf mais
c'est un truc de fille mais comme il est
un peu dans tous les
[Musique]
sacs à main c'est bizarre
ça commence à les gi way
au nom
bien
c'est john qui conte les petites
cuillères
en fait moi j'utilise beaucoup de miel
et tout pour la voile et donc du coup
comme y'a jamais depuis hier donc j'aime
le joueur de tottenham à la nasa ça
c'est pas un sac j'ai c'est une valse et
pour alain delon tuer la cuillère
[Applaudissements]
et a dû voter nicolas sarkozy pour faire
plaisir à un tueur
à personne c'est drôle mais
aucun des deux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
meetic par les adversaires qui a bossé
comme eux pas de boules de pétanque
ou non a
pas de boule d'énergie
a peut être aucun des deux noms n'y a
rien eu sur gaza
il a pas de déviance à m qu'est-ce que
tu parles bonheur en main qui vous ne
peut-on pas une censure inferno pages
web et lire une hausse est même de la
mort et a pas les boules de pétanque ou
non
mais bon comment avec une pochette en
cuir haye mais on n'est pas un passé pas
vraiment les peindre les tremplins oui
d'accord sont trompés dans un dance
espèce de chose qui les rend brion
l'essor only sèche une demi joués bien
ça une sorte de vernis mais il ya
différentes couleurs on peut peindre le
vernis on peut les faire dorer on peut
les faire brillant enfin là ça devient
longue date
à l'issue de ce jeu il obtient 9 à 7
elle bande annonce
[Applaudissements]
et
1 troisième épreuve l'auto quiz
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
très sain chacun d'entre vous aura 60
secondes pour répondre à un maximum de
questions en rapport avec sa vie chaque
bonne réponse vaut un point on va voir
si vous connaissez bien votre propre vie
on commence avec vous claudia et bruno
patrice et régis vous jouerez après
bruno c'est à votre tour attention vous
êtes prêt
contre toi parce que si tu es
quel était le premier filtre des
guignols les arènes de l'info
comment s'appelle le futur mari de votre
fille
sébastien mariage en septembre premier
quelles furent les trois premières
marionnettes fabriquées pour les
guignols
ppd aux craintes et gainsbourg qui a
adapté les costumes dans la nation
française 2 avenue q ue
pourrait passer je sais pas sophie
boudard wickham il pas raison on va
faire saisir
comment s'intitule est le premier roman
daniel michaud dictionnaire misogyne non
roman sissi impératrice il y retrouver
bâton quels sont les ingrédients des
spaghettis à la ricotta bruno gaccio
alors la ricotta
de2
mascarpone
celle du corian bons trucs comme ça on
mais clariant exact
qui logeait avant vous dans
l'appartement que vous avez occupé avec
al rai duras
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
y habiter de 1940
2996 oui j'espère qu'elle n'a pas les
siennes et bouquins elle a laissé des
écrits sur une étagère gesson sur la
tranche d'une étagère il ya manuscrit de
sa propre main
manuscrits duras refusé
collector alors continue avec vous
claudia qu'avez vous découvert à l'âge
de 9 ans a jeté noir oui
je sais comment
c'est très bien c'est en larmes de
l'école en disant mon père pourquoi j'ai
pas de taches de rousseur et tout ce que
ma meilleure amie à l'école française en
côte d'ivoire elle était rousse haider
il m'a dit ben regarde toi dans la glace
je sais pas quoi
ah oui effectivement j'ai vous voilà la
bonne réponse
c'est quoi le mac ou pas assez une danse
est une danse appelle communément
c'est mon traitement
et faire
ainsi que les faire ça il faut avoir du
relief
[Applaudissements]
bataille nous attend ce matin
mais dense maintenant
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'aux panneaux
soudés
occasion
[Musique]
antoine lejeune
un art dont antoine le jeune cadet se
connaît on sait pas si c'est parce que
c'est votre metteur en scène travaille
c'est
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
énorme
mu est bien abidjan qu'elle lagune
traverse la ville d'abidjan comme lagune
ébrié bravo selon vous dans votre
carrière qu'est ce qui a été un frein
plus important que d'être noir mât
boultif away pour
[Musique]
[Rires]
compléter cette phrase de vous même j'ai
une boîte à rêves très lourdes et non
pas la transporter elle est presque chez
l'autre que monde
vous avez suivi les cours de théâtre
voilà les scores de 19 pour bordeaux
c'est bien visible et de 7 pour vous
mais vous n'êtes pas encore commencé à
jouer on commence avec patrice carmouze
à sera quel âge avez vous eu vos cheveux
blancs 22 50 points quelle est la taille
de christophe dechavanne 1 m 60 e non
combien de centimètres de boue de plus
christophe dechavanne 9
ça allait bien à vous pas
non combien de points rapporte votre nom
scrabble sont venus
18 heures j'étais l'invité de la 100e le
ciel mon mari christian clavier vous
aviez soutenu bayrou en 2007 15 corps
avait été obtenu au premier tour de la
présidentielle
17 pour 18 58 50 euros qui est jean marc
lubin sant maclou la cellule où le
service est arrivé que n'avez vous
jamais révélé sur votre vie privée
tout
tout je savais que c'était avant
pour quel ouvrage michel field est il
venu comme invitée dans ciel mon mardi
un pastel admin on
n'a pas assez un point d'honneur
en terminant les jours et this way
quel est pour vous le seul aveugle qui
donne envie d'être sourd gilbert
montagné mare d'eau
dans votre spectacle comment surnommé
vous johnny hallyday et eric cantona
frères lumière ouais fait
[Musique]
compléter cette vanne de votre spectacle
fadela amara est rentré au gouvernement
ni ni soumises un toujours pas put
avec quelle célébrité avez vous déjà
couché liliane bettencourt
temple et et 7 passes de vous mais un à
côté du difficile français bernard
madoff c est jean valjean corps et piqué
en fin d'année
qui faisait le chauffeur de salle dans
les agités du bocal
je bosse mathieu madénian oui pourquoi
sur celles dites vous c'est normal
d'avoir le portrait de nicolas sarkozy
comme n'importe quelle mug à le portrait
de son mac à wil c'est la personne qui
m'a le plus baiser depuis les cinq
dernières années c'est pourquoi vous
avez joué de nombreux mois au casier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'issue de l'autre poule et instaurer
des 19 euros et le vainqueur bord obama
voici d'entre nous qui avaient le plus
de chances de faire de la promo tout à
l'heure mais mais mais le jeu n'est pas
fini la quatrième épreuve larbi quiz
[Applaudissements]
là tout le monde joue en même temps tu
interview à ma façon vous appuyez sur le
buzzer quand même pas fait avoir la
bonne réponse voilà comme ça
assurez-vous toutes les réponses parle
de vous bien une contrainte ce soir les
réponses doivent se terminer en haut
je donne un exemple qu'est ce qui est
tout petit mais que vous aimez bien les
papous les petits kangourous les petits
toutous ou passe partout
voilà pas compris du tout voilà celle en
extérieur
revient sur les messieurs
attention et en plus la première
question est vraiment pour bruno gaccio
avec quelle phrase draguer vous
généralement
[Musique]
non je crois que jamais prononcé cette
phrase il ya aussi je suis une célébrité
on fait ça ou
quel dictateur vous manque et tout
à
tanger dire un truc magique quand on a
dit il faut répondre
et qu'est ce qu'on fait on se partage le
droit
quel métier n'existe pas
coupât petit nom est un instrument sanaa
oui c'est vrai mais c'est pete wentz
[Applaudissements]
attention quand on fait l'amour quel est
votre position préférée
à la mairie non trop bas vous moi
[Applaudissements]
on est moindre et
merci attention bien aussi
[Applaudissements]
ma femme regarde ne le dit pas quel
prénom ne 2 ne riez vous pas à vos
enfants
oui mais
quelle jolie fille
appréciez-vous particulièrement bas
[Applaudissements]
yannick tout aille bien
georges pompidou
quel est votre footballeur préfère
facile
c'est cadeau
vous vous érigez route je joue
[Applaudissements]
lizarazu zizou
s'est
défaussé gardien du psg
alors ça c'est pire est que s'il a
répondu avant ça s'écrit avec
ses mix du monde ici réduit alors c'est
le gardien de la personne âgée c'est le
sujet numéro deux dé garder à l'italien
serbe ophone
pointures du bouffon
là on est obligé c'est vous c'est
fallait y croire j'y pense et sirigu ai
pas pensé zizou
l'équipe tous les jours attention quel
est l'animal dont vous vous sentez le
plus propre kangourou
[Applaudissements]
ça peut être ça mais parce que j'ai un
truc un nombre de trucs incalculables
dans les poches aussi greg
attention qu'à l'humoriste vous fait
bien marrer
michou mais c'est pas vraiment elie
kakou oui
mais il échoue il est aujourd'hui
cependant la première proposition ainsi
chantal
[Musique]
nous avons du mal à
écouter à l'issue de ce jeu wii 26
points bongo
[Applaudissements]
mais rassurez-vous la route est longue
et maintenant on termine avec l'épreuve
reine de ce jeu le music quiz
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors vous devez reconnaître en fait
l'intérêt l'interprète chansons font
référence à vos vies mais ce que je veux
c'est 90 3 points par bonnes réponses
inutile de vous dire que tout est encore
possible mon chère patrie sans cesse
jouer voilà quand vous pensez avoir la
bonne réponse vous baisez attention
bruno ce morceau vous concerne
david
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oula
là je dois dire la première note quoi il
a dit le nom du groupe
aujourd'hui en clair et bien un mec moi
ouais mais j'en ai dix
heureusement
même tout sonne elle il faut savoir en
temps partagé
exact bon si c'est des battues par huit
manches
[Rires]
et le problème du dimanche c'est qu'elle
travaille pas
[Rires]
alors bon alors évidemment un autre
monde pour bruno gaccio à cause de son
côté un peu utopiste oui mais en même
temps très réaliste rallyes terre que la
promotion vous permettra de parler de
roosevelt 2012 je tente encore de gagner
et c'est bien sa revue 1002 mais ça
c'est un morceau pour claudia vidéo
[Musique]
tiken jah fakoly doigts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les appelant
à ces dictateurs en plus ivoirien comme
bodmer est à l'abolition voilà
ça sert des plats du mans
il est bon ce maillot un bon
effort cesar manso pour toi pas tout
attention david
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si tu fais à nouveau
le demandera
[Musique]
on absolue
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
david
martinon
dalida bah oui oui oui dans
quels cas déjà
qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant moi je
peux bien me chier une fortune ouais ça
va mais si elle a dit en premier donc
c'est claudia
[Musique]
normalement tu as pu mais tu dois dire
le nom sur ses appuis et tu cherches
pendant une bonne heure assez bon au
risque que tu prends c'est que quelqu'un
le dise à ta place à gignac en tire pas
infléchi samian séance la ville
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un leader honni j'attendais c'est
pour ça que ouais c'est pour toi
david
[Musique]
family 1
au monde
et là
c'est à cause de la victime
[Applaudissements]
georges benson 0,8 à leurs
révélations
[Musique]
kiev
mais bon
et
attention un morceau qui concerne
claudia nous en avait fait la parodie se
retrouve david
[Musique]
non
non non
savait pas que les gens sont tous
là
il a droit
[Applaudissements]
m à
[Musique]
oh
mais
[Applaudissements]
j'étais ravi examinons comment ciel
ça et me voici
la dignité
vers enfin
ça
mais
je ne suis guère voir
super voir si
vraiment il ya quelque chose ah
bon alors patrice et pour vous mon cher
ami avoue david
[Musique]
je vaux les épaules et les yeux
un indice son prénom est celui du plus
grand chanteur de rock and roll du monde
elvis
la vie ski cost euro bonds
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'écrivais des
responsables
sberbank
sinon à la la c'est chaud quand ça c'est
une chanson aurait vis à ce poteau mais
c'est claudia qu'il va trouver
valide
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ses partenaires c'est un jeu
[Musique]
je touche entre
amis
je ne peux pas la scène mal
pour toi
[Musique]
ce parti pour le
[Applaudissements]
cris va
sceller essaye de souffler et n'étant
même pas c'est un trans qui a dit sister
sledge
bravo
[Applaudissements]
alors
il vient pour lutter
révélations
[Musique]
oui
m
hier j'avais très dur pour vous deux
ouais vous êtes prêt à encaisser le coup
le choc les coups fatals ouais ouais 38%
[Applaudissements]
et voilà c'est donc vous qui allez faire
plus de promo que bien
mais d'abord d'abord
ça va être très vite expédiée en la
promo des perdants patrice et l'abonné
reçoit avec ses fans maire
régis votre chronique la marque du
mailhot devedjian sur rtl et paris
première tous les mois
et vous mes amis
vous avez tout votre temps le
tchador en tournée dans tu peux
apprendre avec one man show au crazy
également bataclan du 31 janvier au 3
février 2013 et si vous n'avez jamais eu
de gaffe sur scène allez-y c'est quelque
chose
mon petit bruno alors la communauté du
cac l'avenue ku en tournée dans toute la
france à partir du mois de janvier wen
en partir du mois de janvier une
quarantaine de dates et puis après en
retour à paris très très très probable
réussir aux halles 2012 roosevelt 2012
point fr il faut juste aller voir une
quinzaine de propositions qui permettent
quand même sans croissance parce que la
croissance on en aura pas et ce en
croissance on peut y arriver ya des
mesures à prendre qui sont assez simples
mais il faut pour ça tordre le bras à
quelques banquiers et aux est un petit
peu et si françois hollande est monsieur
et rose mais iront un peu plus loin les
couvrait toute la vie
bruno gaccio nous nos restaurants
il a gagné cette émission est de sauver
d'apprendre que vous le faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci à claudia prénom à patrice aziz
merci à toute l'équipe qui m'a aidé à
faire cette émission et n'oubliez pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu